[Music]
hello and welcome to this video this is
a video about line in the rougarou's in
that you will definitely face quite
frequently and this is with the early
trade on d5 so let's start so we get
them Queen's Gambit rogozin and now this
video is about white capturing on d5
this is a very common move and the
resulting positions we can put this on
the board will of course recapture with
the pawn the resulting positions also
might occur Byam different move orders
for example white might play Bishop g5
first and then take on d5 or for example
one of the main moves here is to check
on a4 you could also start with the
check and then trade so um the common a
thing about all these position is to
trade on d5 we look at this here from
this move order but as mentioned it can
happen also a little bit later and then
it will transpose into this chapter so a
very important type of structure um the
main thing to recognize here after the
trade is that our bishop on c8
immediately gets opened up so we have an
easy way to develop this bishop quite
often this is a difference to other
positions after ya if white does not
take on d5 because with the pawn on e6
you still have to work for this bishop
to come out so why does white trade in
the first place white has something here
that is there can be a long-term factor
he's got two Center pawns and we only
have one so oftentimes with this trade
white tries to establish a central
advantage sometimes even by playing
something like this but this is not so
easy in this kind of variation because
the knight is already on f3 in a queen's
gambit declined exchange variation this
sometimes is possible with f3 early on
and then you form yeah not so much the
main reason why the capture on d5 has
any kind of popularity over the last
term yeah over the whole timespan of
this opening is because of the move
Bishop g5 I'm going for the pin without
allowing black to take on c4 this is an
important consideration on White's part
after taking on d5 you don't have to
worry about the pawn capture anymore the
thing is that after Bishop g5 many lines
are playable but in recent years there
has been a new development and there's a
new idea for black that seems to
equalize quite easily and this I think
has taken away much of the incentive for
white to take on d5 in the first place
we will come to this later as the main
line of this chapter first of all we
have to check other moves than Bishop g5
so let's start
but I have to say that Bishop Bishop g5
is by far the main move and the other
move that yachts encounter quite
frequently is Queen a4 check but these
are by far the two main ones
now some others um white can also try
let's say a three to attack the bishop
um the easiest thing to do is to simply
take if you retreat
um you give white quite a useful extra
tempo in an exchange variation of the
Queen's Gambit so you should simply take
and castle our counter place of course
related to the move c5 so something like
this um you can already conclude that
black is fine then counter player dear
Queen a5 is particularly important in
the direct play against this pawn
White's pawn structure on the Queen side
is not really good so this is not
challenging let's go back the move III
is definitely possible looks rather
solid but also passive via the bishop on
c1 doesn't look particularly great we
should [ __ ] prevent any Queen a 496
insertion say that's not necessary or we
shouldn't allow that anymore let's say
because him if you if you check this we
can develop very very freely and quite
often it is possible to play c6 in such
a position and then use the knight in
this way so don't put it on c6
voluntarily here you cannot have any
sort of problem with this excellent
development um III is a bit too passive
I'm Queen b3 that looks more active but
it is not very um yeah it's not very
good for the development side of things
as you look at the minor pieces we
should of course answer in an active way
and c5 makes a lot of sense this is very
much similar to other in cases of Queen
b3 being played early for example white
might play Bishop g5 earlier with our
trading and then we'll be three and then
we have the same kind of counter
for example if Bishop g5 now h6 will
probably transpose to an earlier chapter
but we don't have to do that we can
increase the pressure first
is three and now instead of age six even
have c4 available this is very strong
the Green has to move again and after
age six now white either has to give up
the bishop pair or retreat which is more
likely this was a free preview of our
entire one d4 course based on the
nimzo-indian end recording available on
chess about calm thanks for watching and
see you soon
[Music]